um
right can i welcome all members
and officers to this special pandemic
committee meeting uh i'm david atten
i'm the chair of the scrutiny committee
and can i remind
all members that this meeting is being
streamed
live all members of scrutiny
committee have received um
an email today from
martin dempsey which includes
legal counsel advice
and in light of that uh advice
i will ask councillor wright who
is the executive member for housing and
planning
to make a statement to us are you there
thank you
thank you chair um yeah statement is as
follows the executive decision
made on the 28th of september 2020 has
been called in
on the basis of the ad adequacy of the
consultations carried out
whilst the executive was content the
consultation was adequate
and i submitted a statement through
myself detailing the extent of that
consultation
you will be aware that we have today
been sent a copy of council's advice on
this matter obtained by an interested
party
that advice appears to raise some wider
issues not just in relation to the
consultation
having considered the council's advice
and advice from the council's monitoring
officer
the executive agrees that there is a
need for it to review its original
decision
and to reconsider the matter this will
also enable us to revisit the issue of
the adequacy of the consultation
within the context of that wider review
the original decision will not therefore
be effective
pending that further review i would
propose therefore that on
on that basis to submit to the chair of
this committee as soon as possible
a timetable and outline of the scope of
any further work to be carried out
before the matter is reconsidered by the
executive
thank you chair thank you for that
statement councillor wright i think on
on the advice that
has been given now and on the basis of
the statement
by um the executive member
i accept that we don't need to proceed
with this calling and i note that
any future decision by the executive on
this matter
would be subject to call in
so um having said that
their no need for our calling
meeting really tonight except to uh
have we received um
the statement that we have um so
i'm really sorry to bring you out um
and i think the fact that you know would
receive this
legal advice then it is important that
we heed that and and i thank
the executive mate member for making the
statement that he has
to to take the whole matter back
to the executive okay i'm sorry that
um you know that you've
you know made the trouble to come to the
meeting but
that's the way it is and uh so thank you
very much
for that and i'll have to close the
meeting now
thank you